[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
[Musik]
Sowjetunion januar 1959 die Zugfahrt
dauert zwei Tage und führt durch die
endlose verschneite russische Taiga kein
Problem für die zehn jungen Leute die
Zeit vergeht mit Diskussionen spielen
vielleicht ein wenig flirten und georgis
mandolinenspiel
der Samowar am Ende des Abteils hat
immer heißen Tee was will man mehr ab
und zu wird es spannend immer dann wenn
Kontrolleure vorbeikommen dann
verstecken sich ein paar von ihnen unter
den Sitzbänken die Truppe wollte ein
bisschen Geld sparen und hat nicht für
alle ein Billette gelöst
Ludmilla dubinina ist die jüngste unter
ihnen gerade einmal 21 Jahre alt die
blonden Haare hat sie zu zwei Strängen
Zöpfen geflochten und manchen geht sie
selbst als etwas streng und humorlos
aber auf dieser langen und fröhlichen
Fahrt ist davon nichts zu spüren in ihr
Tagebuch schreibt sie im zu fangen wir
alle Lieder begleitet von einer
Mandoline wir haben gesungen und
gesungen und niemand hat gemerkt wie wir
in eine Diskussion über Liebe und küsse
im Besonderen Geräten Ludmila ist
Expertin nicht unbedingt für Küsse aber
für das was vor ihnen liegt eine
Skiwanderung durch den Ural fernab der
Zivilisation auf einer Route die niemand
zuvor genommen hat sie hat schon einige
Male solche Wanderung die ihr
Expeditionen sind hinter sich auf einer
wurde sie versehentlich von einem Jäger
angeschossen doch nichts konnte sie
davon abhalten sich wieder auf den Weg
in die Wildnis zu machen ihre
Kommilitonen Sinaida schreibt im Zug an
ihre Mutter wir gehen zu zehn campen und
es ist eine tolle Gruppe Leute ich habe
alle warme Kleidung die ich brauche also
mach dir keine Sorgen um mich
wie geht es Dir hat die Kuh schon
gekalkt ich liebe ihre mich die zehn
jungen Leute kommen aus werdelowsk dem
heutigen Jekaterinenburg einer
sowjetischen Industrie und
Universitätsstadt am Rande des
Uralgebirges bis auf Sirmione
solotariofs sind sie in ihren 20ern und
studieren oder haben studiert semion
stößt erst kurz vor dem Aufbruch zu der
Truppe er ist 37 ein Veteranen des
Zweiten Weltkriegs und keiner aus der
Gruppe kantin vorher aber er ist ein
ausgebildeter Bergführer und eine
Bereicherung für die Gruppe alle zehn
sind erfahrene Skifahrer und Sportler
sie sind ausgelassen und aufgeregt sie
sind auf dem Weg in das größte Abenteuer
ihres Lebens für neun von ihnen ist es
der Weg in den Tod
[Musik]
hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem True Crime Podcast
naja wobei Mirko heute ist alles ein
bisschen anders ne hey Toni ja das
könnte man meinen wir wechseln heute das
Genre Richtung Mystery statt True Crime
oder sagen wir es so wir mischen es
true Mystery wir erzählen euch heute
eine Geschichte die als der Zwischenfall
vom biathloff passt bekannt geworden ist
der mysteriöse und bis heute nicht
endgültig geklärte Tod von neun Menschen
die sich auf einer Skifahren noch rum
befanden und was für eine Skiwanderung
ich glaube das Wort Expedition trifft es
besser ungefähr 350 Kilometer wollen sie
zurücklegen durch den nördlichen oral
durch den eiskalten russischen Winter
auf einer Route die nie zuvor jemand
genommen hat die achte Männer und zwei
Frauen sind bestens gerüstet für dieses
Abenteuer naja also bestens gerüstet
nach den Maßstäben von 1959 sie haben
natürlich nicht diese ganze fancy
Outdoor-Bekleidung und die Hightech
Zelte von heute all das
überlebensequipment dass wir uns heute
für ein Wochenende auf dem Zeltplatz zu
legen über sowas hätten diese jungen
Leute wahrscheinlich nur gelacht das
sind keine weltfremden Städter die nicht
wissen worauf sie sich da einlassen nee
das sind sehr sehr erfahrene und
umsichtige Wanderer und vor allem gute
Sportler wir haben ja schon von Ludmila
erzählt die auf so einem Trip sogar
schon mal angeschossen wurde
diese Leute haben schon allen möglichen
Widrigkeiten und Gefahren getrotzt sie
wissen worauf es ankommt wenn man bei
-30 Grad einen Campingtrip machen
überleben und dabei auch noch Spaß haben
will am frühen Morgen des 25 januar 1959
steigt die Gruppe in der Kleinstadt aus
dem Zug von dort nimmt ein
Lastwagenfahrer sie nach wissheim mit
dem letzten bewohnten Dorf in nördlicher
Richtung es gibt eine Menge Fotos von
der Expedition denn fünf der Teilnehmer
haben Kameras dabei und eins der
schönsten stand wahrscheinlich aus
wissei der letzten Etappe vor dem
Aufbruch in die absolute Wildnis darauf
sieht man Ludmilla und Sinaida die sich
bereit lächelnd umarmen und im
Hintergrund da steht Igor glattlauf der
Leiter der Expedition und der schaut
ihnen Lächeln zu da steckt für mich
wirklich die ganze Freude und vor allem
auch die Freundschaft drin mit der sie
sich auf diese Wanderung gegeben haben
okay
die kurzen Moment bitte
Igor dietloff du meinst die atloff wie
in yatlov Pass ja genau das sollten wir
vielleicht gleich mal aufklären bevor
sich jemand wundert der Passi ist damals
nicht so er wurde erst später zum
Andenken an diese Tragödie so genannt
und wo wir gerade bei mysteriösen Namen
sind der später so genannte die
atloff-pass also der Ort an dem die
jungen Abenteurer starben der liegt am
Hang des sogenannten Todesberges ja das
liest man zumindest manchmal aber da
ging wohl bei der Übersetzung einiges
schief die mannsen ein in diesem Gebiet
ansässiger Volksstamm die nennen den
Berg in ihrer Sprache toter bzw
stillerberg und drücken damit aus dass
es für Jäger dort keine Beute zu holen
gibt also keine düstere Prophezeiung
im kleinen Dorf wie scheiße läuft am
Abend ein österreichischer Film im
Dorfclub symphonie in Gold ein
eislaufrevue Film unter anderem mit Hans
Moser und Joachim Fuchsberger
Sinaida schreibt in ihr Tagebuch das
Bild war etwas unscharf aber das hat
unserem Vergnügen keinen Abbruch getan
die Musik ist einfach fabelhaft der Film
hat unsere Stimmung wirklich gehoben
Igor war nicht wieder zu erkennen er
versuchte zu tanzen und begann sogar zu
singen
[Musik]
ja so heißt eines der Lieder aus dem
Film
Igor der Expeditionsleiter ist sonst
eher der ernste Stille Typ aber die
Symphonie in Gold reist auch ihn mit na
ja tun ich will diesen Film nicht
schlecht machen aber es fällt natürlich
aus heutiger Sicht schwer die
Begeisterung zu verstehen na ich kann
mir das nur erklären mit dem Adrenalin
oder mit der Aufregung die die Gruppe
verspürte vor ihrem Aufbruch ins
winterliche nirgendwo war halt eine
typische 50er Jahre schmunzelte ja aber
es sind halt auch die 50er und es ist
die Sowjetunion nach der Stalinzeit
setzt unter Christoph ein wenig
Tauwetter ein und plötzlich können die
Leute so etwas wie kitzige
österreichische Musik Komödien überhaupt
erst sehen das hat vielleicht sein Teil
zur Begeisterung beigetragen obwohl die
meisten von ihnen begeisterte
Kommunisten sind ja das stimmt aber
wärmer so für Kommunisten war es auch
eine Zeit der Begeisterung zwei Jahre
zuvor hatte die Sowjetunion den ersten
Satelliten ins All geschossen und der
ganzen Welt scheinbar damit die
Überlegenheit des Sozialismus
demonstriert es ging wirtschaftlich
bergauf und das Regime wurde ein kleines
bisschen liberaler ja politisches
Tauwetter um mal zum Thema
zurückzukommen nur das im januar 1959 im
Uralgebirge natürlich genau das
Gegenteil von Traumwetter herrscht bei
tiefen Minusgraden macht sich die Truppe
am 27 Januar auf den Weg in die Wildnis
für einen von ihnen den 21-Jährigen Juri
ist die Reise schon einen Tag später
wieder vorbei er leidet an Rheuma und
eine schlimme Attacke zwingt ihm am 28
zur Umkehr er ist der Einzige der diese
Expedition überleben wird später wird
man bei der Gruppe Fotos finden die den
Abschied von Juri zeigen er selbst sagt
aus das ist in der Gruppe keinerlei
Konflikte gegeben habe als er sie
verließ auch sonst seien nichts
Verdächtiges aufgefallen der Rest der
Gruppe setzt den Weg auf Skiern entlang
der Flüsse los war und aus Bier fort ihr
Ziel ist der Berg und Torte am 31 Januar
schreibt Igor in sein Tagebuch langsam
entfernen wir uns von der ostbeja an
sanfter Anstieg die Fichten werden von
einem schütteren Birkenwald abgelöst
dann die Waldgrenze harschnee Karl
Gegend wir müssen ein Nachtlager suchen
wir steigen südwärts ab ins Aus Pia Tal
das ist wohl die Schnee reichste Stelle
erschöpft er richten wir das Nachtlager
es gibt wenig Brennholz das Feuer machen
wir auf Holzstämmen keiner hat Lust eine
Grube zu graben
Abendessen im Zelt hier ist es warm
es ist seine letzte Eintragung 14 Tage
später um den 14 Februar herum soll sich
die Truppe aus wischheim mit einem
Telegramm bei der polytechnischen
Universität in zwettlofs zurückmelden um
den erfolgreichen Verlauf der Expedition
zur verkünden das Telegramm wird nie
abgeschickt am 20 februar beginnt eine
großangelegte Suchaktion freiwillige von
der Universität und zwerglaufs
Polizisten Angehörige des Volkes der
mannsen und Hubschrauber und Flugzeuge
der Armee suchen nach den Vermissten am
25 Februar entdecken Studenten skurren
und einen Tag später am 26 da stoßen sie
knapp oberhalb der Baumgrenze am Osthang
des Toten Berges auf das Lager der
Vermissten
michael sharawin sieht das Zelt als
erster es steht in einer flachen Mulde
ist zusammengebrochen nur Teile der
Planer ragen aus dem Schnee mit einem
Eispickel legt er den Eingang frei im
Inneren sehen er und sein Kommilitone
Boris lobsdorf die Rucksäcke der Gruppe
ordentlich aufgereiht an einer Seite des
Zeltes Skischuhe Äxte und andere
Ausrüstungsgegenstände liegen auf beiden
Seiten des Eingangs neben einem kleinen
Ofen ist Holz aufgeschichtet Michael und
Boris finden die Papiere der Gruppe die
Landkarten ein wenig Geld und eine
Flasche Wodka auf einem kleinen Tisch
steht ein Teller mit Salo eine
Spezialität aus dem Rücken Speck von
Schweinen das ist ein fettes
kalorienreiches mal das gerne von
Wanderern mitgenommen wird
der Speck ist aufgeschnitten als hätte
sich die Gruppe gerade auf das
Abendessen vorbereitet dann entdeckt
Michael die Schnitte das Zelt ist
aufgeschlitzt von innen und draußen im
Schnee in der eisigen Kälte stoßen sie
auf Fußspuren einige stammen
offensichtlich von nackten Füßen oder
Füßen die nur in Socken steckten eine
der Personen scheint nur einen Stiefel
getragen zu haben was kann eine Gruppe
erfahrener Bergwanderer dazu veranlassen
ihr Zelt zu zerschneiden und halt
bekleidet und teilweise barfuß
hinauszurennen in die schneidende Kälte
von
-20°c die Fußspuren enden nach wenigen
Metern Michael und Boris kehren um
zurück nach unten in den Wald zum Lager
des Rettungs
die Flasche Wodka aus dem Zelt nehmen
Sie mit und am Abend am Lagerfeuer der
lehren sie sich gemeinsam auf das Wohl
der Vermissten Studenten wir sollten
nicht auf ihre Gesundheit anstoßen sagt
einer von ihnen sondern auf ihren ewigen
Frieden Hoffnung hat das schon niemand
mehr
am nächsten Tag macht sich der
Rettungstrupp wieder auf die Suche etwa
anderthalb Kilometer vom Zelt entfernt
entdecken Michael sharavin und ein
anderer Student unter einem hohen
nagelbaum einer sibirischen Zirbelkiefer
die gefrorenen Leichen von Juri
doroschenko und Georgi grifonicenko dem
Jungen mit der Mandoline
sie liegen neben den Überresten eines
Lagerfeuers und sind teilweise mit
Schnee bedeckt sie tragen Unterwäsche
sind barfuß und haben Verbrennungen die
Äste des Baumes sind bis zu einer Höhe
von 5 m abgebrochen als sei einer von
ihnen am Stamm hochgeklettert noch am
selben Tag treffen weitere Helfer ein
und sie beginnen den Berg systematisch
abzusuchen zwischen dem Zelt und dem
Fundort der ersten beiden Toten stoßen
sie auf die Leiche von Igor ein paar
Stunden später spürt ein Suchhund unter
einer etwa 10 cm hohen Schneedecke auf
die sterblichen Überreste von Sina
kollmoga aus er ist eine Woche später am
5 märz wird die Leiche von Lust im
slowboarding unter dem Schnee gefunden
die Leichen von
Igor Sina und Russland liegen in einer
fast geraden Linie zwischen dem
Lagerfeuer und dem Zelt der
direktlaufgruppe ihre Position deutet
darauf hin dass sie auf dem Rückweg zum
Zelt waren als sie starben
die Suche nach den verbleibenden Gruppen
Mitgliedern die dauert noch mehr als
zwei Monate schließlich werden ihre
Leichen am vierten mai 1959 in einer
Schlucht unter einem vier Meter hohen
Schneehaufen gefunden keine 100 Meter
vom Fundort der ersten Leichen entfernt
sie befinden sich etwa 50 Meter von der
Lagerfeuerstelle Weg drei von ihnen sind
wärmer angezogen als die anderen und es
gibt Anzeichen dafür dass sie die
Kleidung der zuerst gestorbenen
mitgenommen haben Ludmilla trägt die
verbrannte zerrissene Hose von Georgi
und ihr linker Fuß und Schienbein sind
in eine zerrissene Jacke gewickelt
das große Abenteuer endet in einer
Katastrophe
neun junge Menschen die voller
Tatendrang Entdeckerlust und guter Laune
aufbrachen sind tot aber warum
naja selbst wenn sie nur erfroren werden
hätten wir es mit einem Rätsel zu tun
denn warum sollten sich so erfahrene
schneewanderer ohne Not der kälter
aussetzen aber wie ihr im zweiten Teil
hören werdet sind die Umstände noch viel
rätselhafter es werden grausame
Verstümmelungen entdeckt und merkwürdige
Details auf einem Foto vielleicht Spuren
die sich nicht mit irdischen
Begebenheiten erklären lassen
lasst euch überraschen wir hören uns
morgen im nächsten Teil dieser
Geschichte wieder bis dahin passt auf
Euch auf und lasst uns wissen was ihr
von dieser Folge denkt schreibt uns
gerne per Mail oder per Instagram die
Links findet ihr wie immer in den
Shownotes und wir freuen uns natürlich
auch wenn ihr die Glocke abonniert und
eine Bewertung da lasst danke schön und
bis morgen eure Toni und euer Mirko